[Aplausos]
ante la mirada de decenas de
espectadores el cohete starship de la
empresa estadounidense spacex explotó a
escasos minutos de su despegue en Boca
Chica Texas
en este lanzamiento de ensayo que
representa el proyecto insignia spacex
estaba programado que el cohete se
separara con éxito del propulsor llamado
super heavy tres minutos después de
iniciar el vuelo pero al no ocurrir esto
starship explotó a pesar del incidente
el multimillonario y los musk que dirige
la compañía spacex celebró lasaña que
rompía con todos los esquemas en la
carrera por la conquista del espacio
felicitaciones al equipo de spacex por
el emocionante lanzamiento de ensayo de
starship hemos aprendido mucho para el
próximo lanzamiento de ensayo dentro de
unos meses spacex espera llevar a los
humanos a distancias mucho más largas
dentro de nuestro sistema solar y
hacerlo mucho más rentable también
llevar carga al espacio satélites y
telescopios espaciales un gran reto que
implica algunos desafíos técnicos clave
nunca antes resueltos como operar un
cohete tan grande de 120 metros de
altura con tantos motores y de forma
remota Este no es el primer ensayo que
sale mal anteriormente otros cuatro
ensayos de la compañía han terminado en
explosión